a ご紹介ありがとうございますえー何か様と申します
本日はですねえええ
エーモン実はあロボットとシミュレーションが切れれば飛龍切り開く上水泳の未来と
いうことでお話ししたいと思います
私自身はのさきほどはお話があったの大竹先生
同じ学科であの普段は機械工学をアナ教えている
下
で a
会鈴鹿営業所私の自身の
研究分野はですね先ほどご紹介がありましたように
スポーツ4角の vine をメーカーに先ほどえっとちょっとバイユーイングスバル
さバイオメーカーにませんですねー
ano
またスポーツ幸が食べてまぁ埠頭すると皆さんあの
2大附の先生がいい
だと指を持っていらっしゃると思うんですがそのスポーツに高額をまあ掛け合わせる
ポッいい
掛け合わせるなのがこのスポーツ4角という分野です
スポーツにおけるまあそういう問題を色々な問題を工学の視点を使って工学的な手法を
用いて解決という部位です
また違う言い方で言うと a パパよ民家に空虚でこちらも出場に気がするメカ
ニックスというのは機械の振動を抑えて
そういったことで使われるんですがああそれを生物に使う
整体バイオ度目かに人も掛け合わせるというのがバイオ4ヶ月という分野で後もに非常
に各最適な研究分野と言われています
特にその中で私が研究対象とししてるポッチャマ水泳です私し実はですねもともとは
25年くらい前は魚やイルカの木というのまあの卒論を研究し始めまし
8それが眉 am 812年くらい前から人間の上の研究をする夜になったんですが
まさかな夢に比べると人間の指はような非常に武官
パーなんて不可能
にももうと思うんですねや私自身思いました難敵にじっくりな動きだろうと
ですがまだからこそ非常に研究のしがいがあるつというふうに思っています
水泳というのは皆さんの中でも多分8やってらっしゃる方
青雪が好きだという方があるいは tm のパターンいらっしゃるかと思うんですが
まぁ特に日本人は逆上に親しまれていますあの北島康介とか
オリンピック選手でも活躍が期待されたの金メダルを取れるじゃんということで
親しまれていますってただ親しまれてるだけじゃなくて水流ということはまさかの研究
のしがいがあるといったように
力学的にも見ても非常に膨らんだな現象です
あの日
の水を解決推進力を得る
その仲間に乗っての周りの水の流れています非常に複雑
非常に複雑な現象で遊びは研究の対象で古くからも研究の対象になっています
私自身後機械工学の立場なのでまとめて水を研究するかといった時に舛添機械工学の
牡馬が九紋竜大魚拒否会余興まぁちょっと難しい話は抜きにしてそういう機械工学の
数式や理論を使ってそれを睡魔を良い人役要する you are 金魚して
vector
的に言うとそれをそっとそういう理論
数施行まあ園生の紙とウェブで解くわけじゃなくてシミュレーションソフトを使って
解説するということをしていますでこれがその開発したええええ
手腕というソフトでエトーはどちらもこれインターネット上でみなさーん
ダウンロードすることができませんあとで google でも良かったら数
もで検索してみてくださ左側研究者向けの本当にフリーソフトで右が一般向けアナ小学
生が自由研究でも使えるようにと言うので
降った雨よかったらいいあー残念ながらちょっとあのう
有料なんですがまぁ自由研究とか
使うこと星考えておられたら是非使って言っている
じゃこのソフトを使ってい
何ができるのかという話なんですが
まずこれがそのすワームによる解析激化というあの
8シミュレーションとデブソフトの解析結果画面ですねこれとある
影響へ某競泳選手の訪問
実際に盛り返してきたものなんですが岩井代表的な4 a
です
で a
たらこ例えば9左上のクロールを見るとってから赤い線学校でてますがあれがその手に
働いている
流体力守りは自ら受ける力あのあれでいる通りに至る代わりに赤い線が出ているので
左のキロ推進力があるとをしている瞬間に出てきということが終わります
でじゃあこのシミュレーションを使うと一体どんなことができるのかということですね
まあいろいろありまして喋り出すと何時間でもしゃべるんですが
えっ特許はまぁそういう訳にもいきますのでその中の一つだけトピックをご紹介します
クロールの究極の菜食ストロークをシミュレーションで求めることを心
クロールについては皆さんよくご存知と思っていらっしゃるかもしれませんがばこの子
鍋の内側をまでご存知の方はそうはいないと思います
お供との起源を見るとまぁ古代エジプトまで遡ってみてあのエジプトの壁画にクロール
のようなあのフォームを良い
行きがが実際に発見されています
でえっ発生したのはですねまぁヨーロッパ出かけレースのために思い発表
今の原型ができたのが1870年ぐらいで
まぁちょっとまた足でなくでハサミやせんですちょっと違うのでしたが大嫌いバター c
ができて今や普通に言われているの6 b とクロールわけですがそれがねから
だいたいそれから100年前ます
私はこれを聞いても勝たなきゃ100年前の年皆さん100年力すごい昔かもと思うか
もしれませんが
マッセイで賛成代ぐらいはないということでえええ
高中100年前
皆さんスイミングスクール言ったら長くロールというとこういうんですよんてんご学校
で教わっているかもしれませんがとてもそれはもうバッチリするって決まったものでは
なくて絶対的なものじゃ全然ないっていうことですより実際オリンピックレベルで見る
と例えばクロールと言っても
ての前方が結構変わってきます
年前と今では結構好調いうことで買ってきています
じゃあもしかしたらそのまだ誰も見つけてなくてもとと早い最速の栄光なってことが
あるんじゃないなというふうに私にしが思いました
それはさっきのこのコンピュータでシミュレーションのツールでいつ家てやれないかと
言う
まあことを考えるわけです
でシミュレーションでやっています a クロールでストーンを込めて舞ってで
コーツィ中に水を書き方
os jis 登録 face の子とか愛の人がいろんなことが言われているんです
がそれをコンピュータのシミュレーションを使って解くとどうなるんだということを
やりました
最適化計算とやっぱり今のエンジニアリングの手法があってそれで愛を使っていこうと
思います
題材は2万体ぐらいいろんなな方を試すとどんなストロークが最速かがわかるように
なりますまあこれがシミュレーションいいところであの実際の政治にい満開ちょっと
ずつ違うにを入れてくれてます
2ちゃんねるなというふうに怒られるのがオチだと思うんですがあコンピュータだと
ほか何も言わずにやってくる
数日間かかりますがそれでももちろん実際行ったんですよりは早い
ということです
あの途中データにはまあ非常にいろんなものが出てきますこれに満開の最初の方に出て
きた奴が出社
5初心者になる
がありますテント左側もうなんかぐるぐる待って溺れているのかというようなんですよ
リンカーはこれが出た時私は彼はこうきたカード関心逆に慢心したんですが
右を手で以上普通に棲み処返すところで逆に書いて足先の方に進んでいるという
ですまあでもこういったものはどんどん淘汰されている8どんどんいいえ
a ものというのが見つかっていくわけです
チェイサー親戚にもっと待ったアーサクロスポロ系あっアティ実際に先進地域差と逆に
言うとそれ実際の選手に次回 here
がコンピューターシミュレーションから出て嫌って2まあ結構いいのあることだと思っ
ています a
伊佐那および収益は0.9だいたい1秒間に十両強化服とか
計測図が2m パーセントこのあたりだいたい
実際の選手
短距離の選手と同じくらいの与えられてい
でこちらは及ぶ速度に正いないというので計算したけどこちらはもっと calling
最大無駄なくを呼ぶ時はどうすればいいかというときのポーズですでそのちょっと秀裕
はゆっくりで a
速度所もうちょっとゆっくりですねっ
はいはいエルボーと変わりたい筋っぽい學會えるボートがいたんですが hi lo
ってなんですねこの日時の肘を高く保ったままこう書く
こういう状態でっていうのが hi lo でテクニックであの
今の水泳の長距離でまあもっともトップ選手である中国の孫楊選手選手
ますが阿蘇の孫楊選手中に見られるばテクニックが実際にこういう構成たんで
シミュレーションから出てきたということです
ブーブー言っなぜこれが良い日 iq 距離とか種目を変えるとじゃあそろそろ
さらにませんしフィードバックするためにアジアどの筋肉を鍛えれば効率的にあの
配分行き
といったことを開き今も取り組んでいるところです
でまぁ今はちょっと計算上の問題計算時間の問題でなかなかあの手の書くところだけし
ができなかったんですがやっぱりまだまだプロール7日よりももっと速いを言い方が
あるんじゃないか自信を持ってまして
そういう中でも究極の背側有望というのが将来解明できれば
持っています
a 棟少し話が中を用意しだてこのようなシミュレーションをするときにその
シミュレーションの精度を上げていこうというと実際に例えば水で後手をかいたときに
どれぐらいの力が
て皮膚があるのかっていうを図る必要があります
でそれは実際の選手
2位でその力を図る非常に難しいです
それを我々窓をもっと使ってかかるということをしてい
でこれは誰のために開発した水中ロボットアームてるんでまぁでいるもんですで正品
箕面川のようにま足にもなりますでゲーム8にもなるんですがこういうのを使って
コーチからを図っている
えこれは手足の場合ですが
胴体ですね筐体の方に働くような流体力を測定しようというのでの声マネ吟醸の
動かしたいというようなマネキンロボゼロと思っています
猫の老舗マネキンをさらにこの招きの手足を動かしてやればこれはもうヒューマノイド
じゃないかということで
ペア者も僕松井 au 愛同ロボットですはままよとた付けてるんですがまぁとよ
ロボットを開発しましたこれある youtube でも諏訪魔の間で計算すると
音が鳴りますねぇー
いきますでこの今の実験だと思う a 棟
水槽中でに設置されていますのでまあ中いう4本の支柱のようなもので支えられている
映像なんですが a
さらにま声27清掃の中に困らないで伊佐のプールでも泳げるようにしようという
マケン姫もしてまして俺あの頭も台のは除くゴホウラの田町の国外で産んで
青と黄
お前は
girl
こんな風に今実際にクロールで泳ぐことが出てくる馬刺しもしてちょっと見づらいです
が私もグッ
ねうことがねえ
でまだちょっと方向性がトカゲた声でき中で俺奇跡的に撒かず館内でたまたま真っすぐ
行っているという
でまぁこのあたりのロボットの改良っていうのも今現在
ということでええまあこういういシミュレーションのまロボット研究の未来はという
ことで
ええまあより詳細で恋ロボット研究を使ってより詳細で高精度になっていけば
水泳経験の強力なツールになって食べて色々なことが解明できるようになるのではない
かというふうに思っています
まあそのためにはシミュレーションのそも精度の検証ですのが向上といった街道な
取り組みも重要であると思っている
今今日はたい方が結構いらっしゃるので25年間の私の閉店研究生活でた場
同鎮政府があっちょっとしたメッセージを最後にちょっとだけお話します
まず1点目は信念を持ってやり続けるということでは例えばこういう研究でもあんな
シミュレーションダメじゃないかとまあ中か外で私も色々言われてたよ
ですらそんな陰口とかな中で目ぐらいねー
100カイ頃から101回親があればいいと言うんですあの私のモットーです
a どんなこともだいないヘッジを持って10年ぐらいやればモノになると
ので心理を持ってやり続けていくのが重要だと思います
あとだったらそれと官界のようにも聞こえるんですが他人に対して心を開くあの
批判を受けたときはまその批判も真摯に受け止めるだろう
あんな批判はあの私もないよと言ってこう頃閉ざしてしまうねいいことがもっと重要力
ですね
あの自分自身がそのターンインの日案を今降る日あったら自分を磨くアニェッリ中欧
旅行4
だから彼にのひまり感をする暇があったら自分を描いてある
を見たかっ
ことを
欲しいなというふうに思います
以上です午前中は良いていた